ah this is really rich sanctuary cities
are completely melting down after
getting just a tiny taste of biden's
border crisis chicago mayor laurie
lightfoot sending a group of migrants
who were bussed to her city
off to a nearby illinois suburb suburban
town meanwhile washington d.c muriel
bowser declaring a public emergency as
busloads of migrants continue to arrive
an a d.c councilwoman who once
celebrated her city's sanctuary city
status is now complaining about the
surge
so it's been said but it's worth
reiterating that the governors of texas
and arizona have created this crisis
and the federal government has not
stepped up to assist the district of
columbia and in many ways
the governors of texas and arizona
have turned us into a border town
so greg set us straight is this a crisis
created by uh the governors of arizona
in texas or somebody else it's just
beautiful that's what it is a really
obvious point uh if the republicans were
running the cities the way the dems are
with this sanctuary hypocrisy they would
be branded cruel and inhumane right
because
and because that's what they if the
republicans are running the cities with
the way the crime is homeless drug
addiction they would be they would be
deemed cruel and inhumane but they get
it passed by the media on this and
another way sanctuary cities are the
worst false advertising they could brag
about their compassion without actually
following through they're what i call
the stolen valor
in the compassion world and it's about
time they get found out what texas did
was they turned sanctuary cities into
border towns which are authentic
sanctuary cities because the border
towns operate that way for people coming
now they're actually they should be
thank she should be thanking texas thank
you for making me not a hypocrite now
i'm truly a sanctuary city what an idiot
she is boy and dana here you have this i
mean the small number of migrants coming
into these liberal cities and they're
losing their minds melting down where
arizona and texas are getting absolutely
flooded yeah so i would love to ask them
what do you think governor abbott and
governor deuces should do then what do
you think they should do instead like
please tell me and i would love for them
to label their application for their
state of emergency the sanctuary state
of emergency because that's what that
was self-created and i just cannot
believe how irresponsible lori lightfoot
is in chicago so she's getting the
migrants she's mad i understand she's
mad but instead of trying to figure out
a problem or going to dc and saying you
got to fix this mr president though i
think she was going to go to dc
uh she just bust him to the next town
and didn't tell the mayor didn't give
him a heads up so that's good it's a
good it's a really good point danny
because jessica you have you do have the
mayor lori lightfoot who was complaining
about uh governor abbott she called him
a racist unpatriotic on christian for
busing migrants to her city and what
does she do she puts the same migrants
in a bus and sends them out of the city
to another town just passes the buck
well people do prefer the suburbs
i i've heard that um if she actually
didn't call the mayor that she was
sending them to that is
insane political faux pas and so unfair
to do and you guys know where i stand on
this i think that the federal government
has to step up this is certainly part of
the crisis that they created and these
sanctuary cities but you're getting a
busload of 75 100 people what is the
huge freak out you're talking about a
city like chicago or new york city dc is
smaller obviously but there is there is
space for these people there are
resources for these people if you want
to stand by your policies and i believe
in sanctuary cities
find the money joe biden give them the
money if they need more for this and
make sure that until people can go
through the court system and i believe
in showing up for your day in court you
can accommodate them but this this game
of ping-ponging people from buses
i really it makes me
i hate this emotional it makes me sad
the idea that these people who are
coming here for a better life are now
being used
on both sides just as you know a cable
you know a cable news conversation
aren't they happy to be in america
whether it's chicago nobody feels good i
think about being used in a fight like
this i don't understand they don't they
don't think they're being used they
think they're getting a free ride to new
york city washington or chicago these
are cities they heard about they want to
come to new york they want to see the
capital they want to be americans right
you need to see washington dc now what
what really infuriates me about this
nonsense these lying hypocrites is you
send 300 people to chicago and lori
lightfoot needs to send them to a
republican town this is folks the new
redistricting it's going to not go
through the courts it's going to be done
by governors mayors and and other other
county officials when they start moving
the immigrants into republican areas
that's what's going on here it is a
national reduction
and if you if you oh now yet in new york
they had them vote wait let me finish my
three cents here now the bottom line is
that these people are coming here we're
giving them housing education medication
free uh where do they just say you get
free health care and we've got we've got
a problem with inflation we've got a
problem with people buying food we've
got a problem with people buying gas how
many millions have to come here how many
towns have to be overrun before we say
okay that's enough it stops when you uh
democrats understand that these are
venezuelans that are coming in and
venezuelans actually hate socialism and
communism they go hey they're not gonna
vote democrat they might vote republican
that's when it changes all right hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else